after drinking Josh what was going on
before you linked up with David dobrik
so I got beat on social media like in
2013 inadvertently with the Vine app and
I just did it for fun because I liked
watching comedians on there and within a
year I was hit the number one person on
it a brand hits me up in some emails
like we'll give you a couple Grand to do
this thing on Vine if you want I was
like okay it was the first time I'd made
money outside of the Showbiz structure
and our friend Jason Nash calls me he's
like I'm working with this kid David
dobrik he has an idea for a bit do you
want to come over and shoot it we did it
was fun and I just remember thinking if
he calls me to do something again I'll
do it and he called me every day for two
years